this simple-looking blob is actually a
swarm of millions of magnetic
nanoparticles the swarm is controlled by
a rapidly oscillating magnetic field
[Music]
modifying the magnetic field allows the
micro swarm to move about it can also
change direction and shape split-up
rejoin and even move through a maze
[Music]
the idea is to imitate the swarms found
in nature and animals like birds or fish
these groups of individuals together
form large shapes but they're much more
flexible in a single large creature
would be the same can be said of the
micro swarm it's strong enough to
manipulate small objects but flexible
enough to fit through narrow spaces this
technology may have medical applications
perhaps delivering drugs around the body
or acting as a contrast agent for x-rays
or ultrasound scans but although this
micro storm is pretty good at getting
through a simple maze the inside of the
human body is a much tougher challenge
tricky obstacles like fast flowing blood
cells and highly salty solutions can
complicate things so a lot more work is
needed before magnetic nanoparticles can
start swarming around inside your body
you
you